good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
thursday we're on the latter half of the
week congratulations jackie you did it
you made it we made it it's always a
beautiful sight to see on a thursday
plus we've got a little daru here today
he wanted to come in because he too was
really quaking at last night's episode
of real housewives of orange county and
he wanted to be here for the recap to
make sure his points were were noted i
would love to hear what he thinks so he
will be speaking up he's going to rest
and then he will be speaking up during
the tv recap segment of this show which
is at the end as you know very very
exciting we've got a great show for you
guys today lots to discuss lots of fast
food you have a lot to discuss a whole a
wide array of stories it's that time of
year where like every publication every
app is doing their year round blank of
the year we don't have any blanks of the
year today it's just like i'm having pts
no not ptsd deja vu from last year i
feel like at a certain point like every
at the end of every year it's like
spotify rapt time person of the year
like all these things happen at the end
of the year sort of i was like we're
always just like recapping yes i would
love to have a blank of the year today
but there is none that caught my eye did
you see rolling stone released their
like 50 best songs of the year no
all too well 10 minute version was
number two what was number one um
a wiz khalifa song i hadn't heard okay
cool you know they love like i didn't
know half the songs on the list like
rolling stone in order to like maintain
their image like has to throw in like a
bunch of [ __ ] you've never heard it
can't just be spotify top 50 what the
actual top songs right what people
actually enjoyed right no they have to
go off book but that's cool for all too
well maybe we'll get some more blanks of
the year next week yeah
as the year comes to an end the last
full work week for us and then as always
we like to do our personal blanks of the
year we do that on patreon like our top
movies of the year top tv shows books
products etc this is just like a bizarre
year like
it's just a day job like this year was
the same as 2020. 100 agreed spot the
difference i can't
can't yeah i love those spot the
difference games at the end of magazines
they're so moronic like they're beyond
they're i think they're for children
right no they're for four yeah it's like
her dress is green and then it's blue oh
i wonder what's the difference but
sometimes they do a very sneaky
difference so they have like 10
differences and the first eight are like
oh my god i could do this blind the last
two you'll never find yeah why is it so
extreme
they like you know i think they want to
stump you um well i've been stumped
jacqueline i'm sorry to hear that claude
um claudeline glenlin monroe
um other than real housewives of orange
county i started a new book last night
which i just need to talk about really
quickly because it's called the
inheritance games people were
recommending it to me so i was like you
know what rose code was so good
recommendation let me read inheritance
games and
you guys
dnr
not a dnr at all if i was 15 years
younger i think i would love it but it's
really like why a you know uh series
like
okay sounds like i would like it yeah
you might like it and i'm gonna finish
it today and it's a quick read and it's
a good book i'm just far too old i don't
know like who was recommending this to
me but it's it's in over me that's too
bad it's a high schooler you know with
other high schoolers
trying to do high school things gotta go
so yeah you might like it but i know
um but you know what it is in a moose
bouche and it does make me crave a novel
of a more serious nature which is what i
was trying to get back to today is also
the sex and the city premiere date and
people are already chatting about it
yeah they say it's not what you expected
i saw a few headlines one episode one
kills off a main character they do they
didn't the headline didn't spoil him oh
i mean i had heard a lot of theories so
you just basically confirmed that it's
true a lot of people could be considered
a main character no but i had heard like
one specific rumor about okay don't say
it oh my god i can't believe you just
spoiled that for me two i saw ahead of
you i don't know if i want to hear what
you have to say anymore this one's an
opinion two i saw a headline that this
new reboot doesn't yet have the spirit
of sex in the city that's what it said
variety i could see that i mean spirit
that's because samantha was the spirit
like was the backbone was
the moment yeah so you'll have to watch
you'll let us know maybe on monday i'm
actually i
where is it one episode at a time i
don't know but i don't think all the
episodes are out i can imagine i'll be
able to recap it tomorrow okay let us
know and i also have to finish the sex
lives of college girls that's like on my
plate right now
yeah that's what's moving my bush
[Laughter]
theo is here he just wanted everyone to
know that he loves you all
and he's been thinking about you and he
knows he hasn't been here a lot but
that's because he thinks he's better
than you so that was theo's message of
the day you know hasn't been here in it
ever ever root did it one time i know i
i honestly forgot that i should like
there used to be a day where every day i
was like is today the day i'm gonna
bring him like thinking about it
strategizing and i haven't even thought
about bringing him in so long i wonder
why maybe next week our final week of
the year yeah we'll have this
responsibility it is but he's such a
sweet love sweet man love boys
i think ever since cheeto gate
you've lost all faith in him i just we
needed to get back to routine we
couldn't be
we couldn't be subbing in so
um well i'm ready i feel ready as well
so without further ado or a brew it is
time for the fast life stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
a new sponsor
which might make the best christmas gift
for someone in your life luminess we
don't have a lot of time to get ready in
the morning so we're always looking for
a way to put on makeup faster and easier
and it's also impossible for us to find
the perfect tone of makeup or makeup
that gives us coverage but still looks
like natural that's why you guys have
got to check out luminess and their new
breeze cordless airbrush system it's a
completely touchless way to put on
foundation fast and easy no sponges
brushes or fingers it goes on with air
and is made for everyday application
within just minutes with luminesce you
get three times more coverage with 10
times less makeup designed to work with
all skin types and skin tones their
clean and water-based foundation quickly
and easily covers fine lines and
wrinkles conceals imperfections and
applies flawlessly so i've had many
makeup artists use the luminesce
products on me and it wasn't until about
a month ago that i got the handheld one
that they um sent to us and it's so much
easier than i thought i thought it was
something that like make only makeup
artists could do but you could really do
it in your own house it's extremely easy
it goes on very natural looking and it's
just a really
fabulous different way to put on makeup
they offer 18 shades and they've got a
color for every skin type that
it has an 18 hour wear so it's a
water-based cruelty free made in the usa
clean product and it has an 18 hour wear
there's so many reviews they're so
confident that you'll love the product
they offer 100 shade match guarantee
so if you've been looking for makeup
forever that doesn't look heavy or cakey
on your face check out the luminess
breeze airbrush it's a really it's also
very not as big as you would think it's
perfect for travel it can fit in your
makeup case
it's about the size of your phone i
would say maybe a little smaller whether
you're updating your beauty routine
because you're heading back to the
office or just looking for a better
faster way to put on your foundation
we've got good news right now if you go
to breezeairbrush.com
toast you'll receive 50 off the airbrush
system
plus free shipping and because your
listener there's a special free gift
included just for you so that's 50 off
plus free shipping when you go to
breezeairbrush.com
don't forget you get 30 days to
experience the airbrush in your own home
or send it back for a full refund makes
a great gift for someone in your life um
but it's also just a fabulous product
for yourself yes
okay our first story travis scott is
breaking his silence on the astroworld
tragedy he sat down with
with charlemagne the god for an
interview that is now on youtube it's 50
minutes i haven't watched it yet but we
have some quotes and i will watch it
yeah i will watch it and i just like
it's one news that he did such an
interview and two here's what he's
saying charlemagne is a good interviewer
yeah travis scott says he is 1000 sure
he did everything to help dying audience
members during the astro world tragedy
in his first interview since the
november 5th hip-hop festival that ended
in the deaths of 10 people scott claims
he didn't hear his houston audience's
screams for help as the victims fell
into peril he said quote i just didn't
hear that
when charlemagne asked him if he did
everything he could an emotional travis
struggled to find the words saying quote
everything i physically could sure yes
and if knowing what was going on you
just wish you could have done something
better but standing there one thousand
percent he also insisted that quote i'm
the type of artist who would have
stopped his show if he was aware that
concert goers were in imminent danger he
said quote anytime you can hear
something like that you want to stop the
show you want to make sure fans get the
proper attention they need i just go off
the fans energy but i just didn't hear
screams i mean like you want to believe
that of course any human being would
want to stop but you see these videos
where it's like you're literally looking
at people
screaming
and you're not doing anything so
i mean i have to watch the interview for
myself i have to imagine this is also a
part of some big
pr push this new uh legal defense that
he has claiming he had there's no
responsibility he had no idea that this
was going on it's all like a part of a
big thing yeah plus i think people are
we are wanting to hear from him and it's
a
weird position to be in because it's an
ongoing legal thing it's such a
sensitive subject it's like you know
alec baldwin sits down it's like nobody
wants to hear from you but then
when we do want to hear from travis and
like want to make sure you know that
he's expressing like i don't know the
grief and remorse that he should be i
could like
don't really need to hear from him i'm
like kind of like disgusted i
i didn't i don't know i didn't need an
interview and i actually when you said i
didn't know this story so when you said
the headline i'm like that's a little
soon no and it's it is a little
surprising but i do feel like other
people that's been a lot of the you know
chatter is like where is travis why
isn't he here for his fans yeah well i
think that he handled it
so poorly with like a couple instagram
videos like an instagram typed out
statement um on his stories which just
was not sufficient and i think that was
handled so poorly i don't i do think
that it's like a little too soon for
this like people are still grieving
people are still
recovering like i don't i just don't
think this is the right time for a
sit-down interview
but there is this like gaping hole from
him like where the [ __ ] have you been so
i think that's because his initial
reaction instagram stories it's all if
you look at his instagram like you
wouldn't think anything happened because
it was all in stories right so what
would you have wanted to see from him at
the time to be in feed
at the time i would have just liked
something more substantial
not this i i just don't i think this is
like a little soon it's a little
insensitive especially off the heels of
his defense
basically claiming he has no legal
responsibility he's not responsible at
all it's just like i don't know i'm like
i'm just kind of grossed out by him and
i i honestly don't need to see him but i
will watch for research purposes but i
like i can't be bothered to care about
what he's feeling i'm sorry yeah it's
it's an it's a weird spot yeah you know
because it's like you want him to accept
responsibility talk about what's
happening but literally he [ __ ] himself
and also we also don't want to hear from
you yeah let's go away for a little bit
like we're still so mad so it'll depend
like the tone of the interview and
um
i don't know you read me like one quote
and it was like a half-baked sentence no
100 like that he did as much as he could
with the information that he had at the
time but he didn't have the information
pretty much yeah i mean and i guess okay
technically if you're on stage and you
don't know all this thing all these
things are going on you can't really
bear any responsibility but you
definitely bear responsibility for
putting on a poorly run event and
encouraging that type of behavior
cultivating an environment yeah where
that's appropriate yeah no and that's
like the pinnacle of the experience yeah
no there's like years and years of of
things you've done
that i think contribute even if you
really didn't see anything going on on
stage yeah like the things just escalate
and escalate right earlier in the day
when people were breaking down fences
getting into the festival without
wristbands like you should have canceled
it before that like before anyone was
even hurt
yeah so i'm just like annoyed with
travis like i'm really not in the mood
to like hear from him and here's the
thing i want to watch the interview in
order to form an opinion but i don't
want to watch the internet i know you
know 100
what platform it's on youtube but is it
like the breakfast club what is it um i
think it's charlemagne's youtube channel
got it so
it is the breakfast club you know i just
saw tick tock this is totally um
unrelated i just thought of kanye
because the last charlemagne interview i
watched was the trump was the connie one
i saw a tick tock that said
lvmh is
prepping kanye to take over for virgil
and it was like this what virgil wanted
they had planned it before his death and
like they have share a similar vision
for what louis vuitton
which like sounds kind of crazy but also
doesn't that would be amazing yeah like
i think kanye has the experience for
sure yeah the talent yeah and the
closeness with virgil i think they
really do share a similar vision yeah so
it hadn't even occurred to me and it was
like a totally unverified tick tock like
no real proof but the idea hadn't even
occurred to me yet
that would be
so crazy i mean i feel like almost the
hype would be too much it's like kanye
makes a
sweatshirt at the gap and it sells out
imagine if he's making
key balls and like like you wouldn't it
would be
it's
like that's the sort of fanfare that
only happens like once in a while for
like a drop you know a collaboration
it's overwhelming it is a little
overwhelming to think about but i think
that would be beautiful yeah i don't
think it's a bad idea at all i'm here
for it me too
but you'll never get another piece no
never oh that's actually annoying right
everything all these prices this
what's it called supply chain i can't
live like this anymore like
shortages shortages they're coming from
tequila you know this tequila cream
cheese shortage now okay and you know
what i want to say i want to say one
thing i've had a thought about the cream
cheese shortage
i blame the bagel store owners because
they have been so frivolous for years
with the cream cheese like a pound of
cream cheese on a bagel nobody needs
that much cream cheese the amount of
cream cheese they put on one bagel i
could literally take and spread and make
three full bagels i agree with you it's
too much cream cheese i blame them but
i'm not going to blame them like this is
their livelihood there's no christmas
and i've also noticed because i actually
have been buying a lot of cream cheese
because i eat a lot of bagels these days
and there's always they're always out of
stock on the cream cheeses that i want i
have to you know ad-lib and i and now i
get like what's your go-to my goat well
pre-pregnancy i love chive but that's
just too much flavor for me now so i've
just been doing plain but you can't even
get like the individual planes right now
i have to get like a block of cream
cheese oh yeah
yeah well that's like a serious thing
that's happening and there's just a lot
and you know i just want to say i don't
want to live like this anymore like i
can't afford anything anymore it's
insane no it's everyone's raising their
prices
what's going on with you sorry my phone
is just um like i put it on do not
disturb but i'm like so popular and
getting so many text messages that it's
still buzzing which is like
maybe but you want to do not disturb
maybe they think you want to be
disturbed but i specifically told my
phone [ __ ] don't disturb me but do you
have this setting on do not disturb
which i just discovered
where you can be on do not disturb but
you can have your favorites your
favorite people they can get through to
you i think that's important i agree i
don't have that setting on and the
person that i just saw was text me is
not on my favorites my favorites is only
my immediate family right okay but i
think that's really good because that
way you know and brian an emergency or
something like people can reach you yeah
i love do not disturb feature i can't
lie yeah no it's it's good stuff just
sorry back to the store i'm sure
there'll be a shortage of do not disturb
soon too so yeah i just never thought
like you know
the economy would be attacking me so
deeply like cream cheese i eat a lot of
bagels and tequila like that's all i
drink and my specific brand of tequila
is having a major shortage in new york
and i just want to say like i'm done
i've also heard there's a chicken nugget
shortage but there's also at this point
it's like just give me a list of what's
not what there isn't a shortage for
because there's a shortage on everything
yeah and i just want to say like i'm
sick of it i want to go back to the
regular life i completely agree it ain't
right no
it ain't right
first they came to get it together first
they came for my nuggets
then my cream cheese then my tequila
get it together no seriously people in
charge like seriously do your jobs yeah
fix the chain fix the chain it's been
going on this the chain has been
supplying for decades
i've had enough we're in 2021 going into
2022. i've had enough we're leaving your
future figure it the [ __ ] out it's
disgusting
are you ready for our next story yeah
jeopardy has found their new hosts for
season 38. you know what's so crazy like
how little i care and how much i cared
like a year ago what i was gonna say is
like what's so crazy is this story and
like this contest like has taken such a
dark turn and it started as like this
beautiful tribute to alex trebek and
like and i think it was actually was it
last year at christmas or the year
before where he passed away i think we
just passed the one-year anniversary
mark okay i have no concept of timing
and so it's been a year of this hunt for
a new host that turned into like this
really fun cultural thing and now it's
turned really dark no it's a social
experiment on cancel culture like and
it's like
please make it stop yeah just choose
choose literally
anyone so
we have two hosts for season 38 but
they're not permanent hosts it sounds
like it's just the season which is just
like jeopardy i know like this was
probably like a fun game within a game
for you guys but it needs to stop like
we're in this like limbo period and what
we all loved about jeopardy was the
stability it gave us all every night
same guy same outfit same concept and
now it's just this like toss-up and it's
really very chaotic and in the unstable
world we're living in jeopardy was the
one stable thing we had and we don't
even have that anymore no and it's
ruining the jeopardy brand and like
what it stands for and also what the
host stands for which was like this
person who was like removed from all
these
things and just someone we could all
rally around and now it's become the
exact [ __ ] opposite and needs to stop
who is it it's mayan bialik and ken
jennings
shuffling
okay you know what i think those are
both great and i have said from the
beginning
that ken jennings should have been the
the next host
it's a beautiful thing he had one
ableist tweet 55 years ago i could look
past it i really can and he's addressed
it a thousand times like what should he
do you know hide in his house forever i
think ken jennings is a person for the
job i've always thought that i like my
inbiolic because she really is extremely
educated but also famous which is just
like a nice little twist um both work
for me oh and she's a jew which we love
both work for me i don't care leave me
out of it ladies and gentlemen this is
growth because it used to be we couldn't
bring up miami alec without you talking
about the lifetime movie that you saw oh
i forgot and without you kind of like
going in on name okay i want to say i
don't go in my on my email i resent that
because i support a fellow orthodox jew
in the space who doesn't back down on
her principles i do not ever ever clown
i think it's beautiful
but i did forget about that christmas
movie she did um and that was
disgraceful to the entertainment
industry and
she should be punished well you know
what she's moving on onwards and upwards
it was a lifetime movie yeah at a
hallmark that's what i said that's that
was what made it low budget it wasn't my
aim it was the network lifetime has a
nice nice chunk of change over there not
for their christmas movies like they
know they pale in comparison so they
just throw some [ __ ] together no i think
that they
they try a little harder than hallmark
these days but they just don't have like
that innate spirit that money can't buy
that chemical like like netflix has
bought the christmas spirit yeah they
found the price and they paid the piper
hallmark has the christmas spirit but
they won't spend any money to elevate it
but that's like what people have always
loved about it just because it became so
popular i liked that they didn't change
who they are they did they're in a way
that was very negative but it's fine not
like negative but just
they stopped trying so hard okay i just
want to go on record one more time
saying i never clowned on mine like i
just i don't want that to be my legacy
like who knows i could walk out of here
and get hit by a bus and the last thing
you said about your sister was that she
clowned on me alec who's a lovely person
i didn't i just really think she
shouldn't have made that movie okay and
i think we can leave it at that
maybe we should bring back toast movie
of the week for christmas and we'll do
that one just so everyone can suffer the
way i suffered i think not
i think enough
no
are you ready for our next story sure
dree kemsley reacts to her husband pk's
dui she says he was barely over the
limit so paparazzi caught wait before we
start i think we should just issue a
major correction of something you said
yesterday
0.08 is not one glass well that's what
the article said okay because a lot of
girls who are in our choice after dark
group they're like my husband's a cop
you have to drink a lot to get to 0.08
but 0.08 is the limit yeah you can you
drink a lot and you can still drive yes
okay yes i would think
if i'm just like thinking what seems
like an okay amount to drink and then
drive i guess it's different for
everyone in your blood alcohol sort of
in your body but i would say two drinks
i wouldn't like if you know you would
say negative drinks and maybe i'll walk
yeah but not walk i'll take a cab okay
but i can't believe point zero eight as
people are saying is so many drinks it
is maybe for a big man
maybe yeah i think for me
i'm just
roughhousing and i also don't even drive
so i don't know
so i don't know
you know but just feeling actually with
two glasses of wine that seems unstable
i don't think i could do there's a girl
on tick tock who like says how many um
she does a different video she's like
how many white clothes will it take to
get me .08 drunk and she's like a tall
skinny girl
she has like four white claws and she's
like over the final like hits the legal
limit
that's a lot of claws that's what i'm
saying it's more than you think it's
also based on your tolerance i don't
know
it's very interesting it's different per
person for sure it's not like a finite
amount no no it is different from a
person because like you have
different bodies weight etc but i do
wonder if your tolerance affects your
blood alcohol because i feel like i have
a low tolerance so two glasses of wine
gets me pretty drunk yeah
so whatever i just he didn't have one
glass of wine is what i'm saying but
they said that he did but he didn't okay
unless like this was his first drink in
50 years right anyways dory was
paparazzi coming out of i think people's
choice awards because that was the
outfit like an after party yeah yeah and
they asked about pk's dui and she said
quote he's very regretful he fully
understands the nature and the danger of
drinking and driving then she said he
was barely over the limit and he fully
understands and reassures me that it
will never happen again when you read it
like the transcript of what she said it
actually sounds like a really nice
thoughtful statement when you watch the
video of her walking out in her dress
signing autographs taking pictures of
paparazzi like looking over her shoulder
while also giving this half-assed answer
to the guy holding the camera it's two
totally different scenarios okay i went
through a range of emotions on this
because when i first watched it it was
it's on our instagram page i watched it
and i was like ooh too soon and like who
answers paparazzi questions like that
about such a serious legal nature like
that's kind of surprising and then of
course she like turns around she's
signing autographs and then i was
reading the comments and people were
like
class all the way like i mean she did
look
unbelievable this was a perfect way to
handle it and i'm i'm like rethinking
about it and i was like yeah maybe it is
better just to answer you are asked a
question you answer it she didn't say
anything untrue and she was very sweet
to everyone around her i don't know if
this was a good move or a bad move i
don't think it was a bad move i don't
think it was a good move i think it was
a move
uh yeah it's a it's an interesting move
yeah and it does sort of i love the
concept of tackling things head-on i
think like whatever scandal you're going
through it's always best just to address
it no but sometimes you're on the side
of the road being asked a question about
a serious legal matter and you shouldn't
be answering that's true like the
sensitivities yeah so
i it was i think it obviously depends on
like the magnitude of what's happened
and i think if she was like avoiding
questions i mean if she didn't answer
the question i don't think this video
would have made the rounds of course not
just another like failed paparazzi
attempt i just want to say that all the
real housewives of beverly hills went to
the people's choice awards and and they
all put together their own looks and
then they got together for a photo and
it was a full-blown circus have you seen
the picture of all seven of them no
clowns
absolute clowns first do you see what
sutton was wearing no i didn't even see
she was there can i show you this
picture i just actually want to get your
genuine reaction to him
and then you can post it to the
instagram because our flow is going to
get [ __ ] up i posted something this
morning it's fine but it's going to get
[ __ ] up over the holidays anyway so
it's fine oh here okay clowns
oh my god just like everyone's on a
different planet and a lot of them
honestly i'm sorry crystal kung minkoff
that dress
burn it
oh i
sutton
burn it okay here
kyle not my favorite
okay yeah okay sutton
not for me um kyle
i'm over it
garcelle looks great yep
rena
looks good yeah she's fine
i don't like erica's look hate i like
crystal's look i do hate and dorit looks
like amazing yeah but together circus
oh for sure they're not they're not
responsible to dress no they're not but
they are there nominated for their show
like as an ensemble they should have
just had their stylist chat i guess
because this picture is clown central
and like i saw a picture of the selling
sunset girls together and did they stare
did their stylists speak
i don't think their stylist spoke but
they all looked
like they were going to the same event
what did you think about um
krischell's new hair so i'm always down
for a hairstyle switch up especially
when it's like
light to dark yeah but she had it was
like two-tone in the front right did you
see that i'm looking at it right now you
gotta zoom in it's like the pieces in
the front were a little lighter than
that's what the tick tuckers are doing i
hate that by the way if the tick tockers
are doing it krishele shouldn't be doing
it
sorry neither should i i agree and i
would say neither should you something
so permanent that is so rude i know i'm
younger than you i know and i still said
it if the tick tockers do it i can do it
no something permanent like that no you
want to get a pair of jeans that they're
wearing on top go ahead yeah anyways but
she looks like cute and i like the dark
hair yeah i didn't notice the frenchie
pieces because now i hate it but i love
when people go dark hair because i think
everyone thinks it's like more fun to be
blonde but most people i know look
better like maturing
is realizing you look better with your
natural hair like most of the time yeah
i thought christine looked great as
always
uh actually i was not into this look it
was giving betty boop like she was going
for marilyn monroe and it was giving
betty boop i just think she always looks
great because like she really can't look
bad no she can't look bad but she could
have looked better the hair it wasn't i
wasn't living i know it's like not your
vibe at all no you know that hairstyle
like really triggers me yeah no i know
and i'm sorry that you had to see that
anyways
before we get into the next story
where do we land on turi speaking to the
paparazzi while posing and signing
autographs
here's where i land tacky but it works
for her i agree and i i think overall
it's kind of a net positive because like
now it's kind of closing the book on yes
this situation that started yesterday
and ended yesterday yes and she also has
so much going on well that's what i was
gonna say jerry really went from being
completely irrelevant to i believe the
star of this season yeah and like given
what she's been going through like i
don't think she needs to add more to her
plate of things to worry about no and
i'm all for personal responsibility
darite did not drive drunk lest we not
forget it was her husband so like maybe
we should i don't know uh be mad at him
for it not her she didn't do it
yeah she was home no i i mean i'm not
mad at her for what he didn't like the
public like
when she's gonna get a request it's like
her no no because she's more famous it's
like her responsibility to like come up
with a statement it's like you know what
[ __ ] that you didn't do anything leave
it to your husband personal
responsibility personal accountability
okay so what about erica jade
she didn't do anything
okay but she was named in certain
lawsuits so yes i would need some
clarifications on that
okay and i wasn't asking her to speak on
tom's crimes i was asking her to speak
on her personal experience
okay and i don't think that's unfair
okay go [ __ ] yourself
[Laughter]
today's episode and jackie's line of
questioning is brought to you by
lollipop a new kind of soda it tastes
just like the sodas we grew up with but
unlike other sodas that are full of
sugar corn syrup and artificial
ingredients and aspartame lollipop is
made with natural ingredients that are
actually good for you so if you've been
looking to switch up stop drinking so
much soda or you're a pregnant lady who
can't drink as much soda lollipop is a
fabulous alternative because they have
amazing flavors like really nostalgic
stuff vintage cola classic root beer
orange squeezed cherry vanilla and they
have a new flavor classic grape um it's
just like a nice blast from the past and
they really taste very very good the
classic root beer there's nothing better
than cracking open one of those and i
feel like regular soda has far too much
sugar but diet soda has far too many uh
chemicals and lollipop is the perfect
balance because it's
made with good stuff it's not so sugary
it's not so fattening it's not so
caloric but you can enjoy a nice pop all
of their products are non-gmo vegan
paleo and keto friendly and the vintage
cola has just two grams of sugar
compared to a regular coca-cola which is
39 grams we've got a specialty deal for
our listeners receive 20 off plus free
shipping on your order we recommend
trying the variety pack it's a great way
to try them all out
go to drink lollipop dot com slash toast
or use code toast at checkout to claim
the deal that's drink lollipop drink
d-r-i-n-k-o-l-i-p-o-p
dot com
toast and code toast also lollipop can
be found in over 6000 stores across the
country including kroger whole foods
sprouts and wegmans also the variety
pack is great because you have it in
your fridge and then when people come
over they think that you have like the
coolest drinks in your fridge because
you have all of these fun flavors and
it's just it's a cool flex yeah
next story celebrity breakup news that
we hadn't discussed yet but common is
now speaking out on his breakup with
tiffany haddish i saw this and i
immediately thought of the toast because
like i
i was very very upset he said we weren't
feeding the relationship common
addressed his breakup with authentic
tiffany haddish for the first time
saying their pack schedules and
dedication to work ultimately led to
their romance's demise all while gushing
over how wonderful she is
um
i don't buy pack schedules i know
schedules is never good because if you
actually really loved someone and wanted
to be with them you would make your
schedules work 100 and if joe jonas and
sophie turner can make it work at the
height of game of thrones and the
bringing back of the jonas brothers then
nobody has an excuse no and i think we
say this every time if nicole kidman and
keith urban can make their schedules
work both dominating their respective
fields couldn't be more different
these two could have made it work yeah
he said first of all i want to say
tiffany as you know is for me like
is for me like one of the best people i
met in life one of the best hearted and
most authentic and caring people that i
met in life and that's what made me love
her and being be in love with her and
want to be in a relationship with her he
said we had a really healthy and loving
relationship it was probably the most
mature relationship i've been in the
communication the respect just all
around
i really thought this was otp like the
way they were so publicly gushing over
each other i was just really excited
about it and i stopped thinking about
them because they were just like a
a stable shipping part of my life yeah
lockers down 100
and
i'm [ __ ] devastated i really am yeah
he said i don't think the love really
dispersed i think it was just like we
weren't feeding the relationship now
that i can understand like if you like i
do think when you are so busy booked and
busy like you also need to put as much
energy into your relationship and if you
don't then yes the busyness supersedes
the relationship and the relationship
will crumble so
but why can't you guys just like we love
each other can't we start nice like we
need to feed so let's go to the grocery
store let's get feeding let's get
feeding i'm like i'm really like like
was devastated by this i thought they
were like a really great couple mm-hmm
well
no that's that that's that i mean it's
the year i mean every year is really the
year of couples breaking up yeah you
just hate to see it but it just feels
like it's all happening like i get lost
and just directed towards us yeah
our fifth and final story is a little
travel news
[Music]
it's the final story
[Music]
fed their relationship somalia
corona beer don't worry you guys we're
not talking about the virus corona beer
will open a private island destination
in the caribbean in 2022 oh my god i
love this there's a new island
experience for corona lovers set to open
in the caribbean sea find your beach
plans for corona island were first
announced by the popular beer brand in
november and it is slated to open to
visitors in the spring of 2022. the
forthcoming hot spot is located off the
coast of colombia and is being described
by corona as a natural island
destination rather than a party hot spot
sure news release said corona island is
unlike anything we've ever done before
as a brand that's so deeply connected
with nature question mark
i know
we wanted to pay respect to and
celebrate the natural environment that
supplies our 100 natural ingredients
okay that's nice but like stop lying you
know you just wanted an island for like
pr and marketing like when i think of
corona like i don't think of
natural natural i mean this is
definitely like a branding move for them
and i think they've been through a lot
in the last year uh as the brand called
corona right but i do think i usually
would think of like spring break
you know
panama city yes
so this is
this is an interesting move and honestly
a good one it's something no brand has
ever done before i think it's actually
very cool is it going to be like you
know open to the public you can like
book a hotel how does it work i believe
it's going to be on the island a hotel
um
yeah i guess so i don't know it's
interesting it's interesting i'm here
for it i love brands thinking out the
box me too and and corona does have like
that iconic tagline find your beach
another like bringing the beach to you
it's great yeah
i like i agree i like when the people do
different things everyone does the same
[ __ ] totally the island will only be
open to certain countries upon opening
in the us because
one of them because of copenhagen i
would i would imagine oh we can't even
go no no you're not invited sorry
yeah but pretty cool yeah very cool and
also
the travelers who can go will have to
take part to enter
in enter to win opportunities which
include qualifying product purchases to
earn miles collecting stamps or finding
a golden ticket
oh it's like charlie it is get in bed
with my grandparents but i wonder if you
could just be like i want to go to
corona island not where i want to take a
trip yeah not i have to buy like a
thousand coronas and hope that one of
them has the winning ticket maybe um
like in the beginning it's gonna be like
sweepstakes and stuff and then like
when like all the excitement wears off
like regular people can just go and buy
or maybe this is just like a limited run
yeah do they buy the island i don't know
now like i hate now i have questions
yeah i wanted to be more permanent yeah
me too when you're right it sounds like
a pop-up yeah and how do you just do
like a pop-up island with uh you know
and have accommodations well i did here
unless they take over jeffrey epstein's
yeah i heard it's empty stop
but no it's not that island but no it's
a different part but a different brand
honestly no it's it's all built out i
bet like it's cursed nobody wants to buy
it you buy for pennies on the dollar we
should crowdsource and have camtos there
same with his uh new mexico ranch yeah
can't get rid of it i mean i i'm all for
a deal but i don't think i would want to
live there no
even like even if i could get a 30
million dollar house for like a million
dollars i still don't think i would buy
it i know i'm saying it's a deal well at
that point we got to be economical you
could tear it down
i just feel like because i would never
want to live in that house oh no no no
no but then like if you twere it down
yeah and then i have to pay to build a
new house nothing yes but you could buy
you could build whatever's in your means
so i'd have this 30 acre property and
like a
100 square foot house how beautiful it's
like yellowstone true
um
also we said we would keep you guys
abreast and
gelatine maxwell no one's talking about
it but she's still on trial yeah all
these photos were released um that
became evidence just like weird pictures
of her and jeffrey being freaks and the
one that everyone's freaking out about
is um
them sitting on
the porch of a house that appears to be
queen elizabeth's house in scotland
which is
moral um there's like side-by-side
pictures of jeffrey and galen sitting on
a bench where the queen has sat which is
disgusting to think about i do imagine
that they scrub the house down every
time visitors come um and a lot of
people are implicating queenie in this
and i just want to say i don't think she
was there with jeffrey and glad i think
her loser son was like hey mom can i
borrow the house for the weekend and he
brought his pedophile friends i just
want to go on record saying that i agree
that's what i assess but there were some
crazy pictures and also like elaine and
kevin facey like in beckingham palace
sitting on the thrones but again i do
think that was her loser son like again
i don't think queen opened the door
pedophiles come in i think she had a
pedophile in her own ranking and she
didn't know yeah and he brought his
pedophile friends around lots of legal
stuff going on right now also josh
duggar's on trial
yes and they gave closing statements and
a lot of people were shook that like it
was kind of short and the jury is just
like chilling yeah also jesse's trials
come to an end and the jury is out for
deliberation we've got a lot of big jury
decisions coming our way yes and also i
saw on little justice news that bethenny
frankel no longer has to pay child
support really
i didn't see that why i don't know but
she's given that [ __ ] so much money
over the years it must kill her
literally no it's not like it's all for
britain like most of it is not no like
when she divorced him like she gave him
half alimony she had just
made her fortune yeah she also just now
she's releasing a book
oh that's good that'll be good i'll read
that it's not it's like an
entrepreneur's guide to being yourself
while becoming successful i don't think
you're going to be interested okay maybe
i don't know about that but um a memoir
i would 100 i think she's actually done
a memoir she's done a lot of books this
is just like a business one that's like
her thing these days like shark tank
what's her show called
the big b big shot yeah big shot with
bethany that's her brand now like
business entrepreneur shark tank vibe
got it okay cool i like that for her um
let's step into the tv gap real
housewives of orange county was so good
and it's brought to you by zip recruiter
think about the major life-changing
moments you've had buying your first car
getting married of course there's also
landing that big job you've been going
for
which can bring new opportunities for
growth higher salary co-workers friends
awesome new achievements whether you're
trying to get your first real job out of
college achieve a new title or land your
dream job you should go to
ziprecruiter.com
easy because zip recruiter makes it easy
to find that next job that could change
your life how zip recruiter acts like
your free personal recruiter when you
create a profile zip recruiter starts
working for you they send you jobs that
match your skills and experience and
they even pitch your profile to
employers whose job match your
experience if someone from that company
really likes what they see they can
personally invite you to apply to their
job so it's no wonder zip recruiter is
the number one rated job site by g2 if
you're looking for that life-changing
job zip recruiter is a game changer they
make your whole job search experience
better sign up for free on
ziprecruiter.com easy
once again go to
ziprecruiter.com easy right now to sign
up absolutely free and put zip recruiter
to work for you
okay
i thought this episode of oc was so good
it was full of highs lows
when i tell you
that when i saw terry dubrow come
downstairs like i was quaking they made
it seem like him and heather were gonna
be like please leave like i was ready
for like the takedown of this woman
who's been like friends with heather for
six years and lied to her
now i assume they wanted to save face on
camera they had been like embarrassed in
their home because they were
unbelievably lovely to nicole she's
dropped the case whatever even though i
don't think her suit had any bad
had any bearing on terry's career the
fact that this woman was in heather's
life for six years and lied about this
is nefarious but i don't think they
wanted to look evil on the show and like
displace this woman
and then they took all their anger out
on shannon and gina so i was like i do
think heather's anger was misplaced
heather's reaction was shocking yeah
like i never in a million of years would
bet that she would find out this
information
take nicole's side and then banish
anyone who tried to come to her with the
news and for most of the episode i would
say up until the last five minutes at
the lunch at the lunch i was like i
really don't think shannon shannon gina
and emily acted in a nefarious way like
i think shannon really
had known this woman is now with heather
heather saying they're friends and it's
like [ __ ] does heather know
that
i was my
i was questionable on shannon's
intentions because you have this
information you wanted to rekindle your
friendship with heather why not just
give her that piece of information
either on or off camera i do think gina
was incredibly genuine and when she
shared the story about the barbecue i
was like oh i understand even more why
you felt weird being in her house i want
everyone to be laughing behind heather's
back i thought gina and emily were
genuine the whole time but like i really
was believing shannon's story which was
like she put this together
if heather knew she probably wouldn't be
friends with this woman so like maybe
heather doesn't know do i want to bring
it to heather and like bring up her
husband's lawsuit on tv no i don't want
to be that person but this is something
that's weighing on my mind i'm going to
get drunk with my friends and i'm going
to spill it to them accidentally and i'm
going to hope that they don't tell her
but now everybody's talking about it
like i really was i could see it i was
believing shannon but then and this is
why heather dubrow is really you know
the queen
when she said
that shannon had told her emily and gina
aren't to be trusted
which is just a shitty thing to say so
it's like why would you trust heather
found the loophole emily
and you had a piece of information 100
so i honestly shannon
yeah it's over no i do feel like
it's a little bizarre to me how
especially like gina and emily and like
a lot of these women are
so desperate to be friends with heather
like
shannon when she was like waiting for
her outside the kitchen it was just sad
because like heather is this a new
generation well not new because she's
old but
this new wave of housewives and if you
ain't with heather like you're going to
be out in a season or two and i also
think they just want to be like cool
with heather how they're so famous how
they're so popular and it's like it's
coming off a little desperate from a lot
of the women like especially gina but i
do think like there's potential for a
great friendship between gina and
heather i agree it is it is like
everybody wants to please heather but i
do think that gina and heather just had
this really like instantaneous bond you
know when you have that with someone
yeah when she saw her earlier in the
evening and she was like i told my mom
about you and and she was like oh my god
that's so funny i told my dad and i
think in that moment gina was like oh
this is someone who could be a real
friend we just had that and so to know
that there's this conversation going
around like i just want to go and tell
my friend i never thought
i nev i thought i was shocked when they
were like it's okay yeah they were like
you sued me why are you in my house no
right before they cut to a commercial
terry was like you're nicole wiese i was
like
oh my god because you know what i saw a
picture of nicole like back in the day
irrecognizable two completely different
people so they they really did not know
no when heather went upstairs and called
off the cameras and went to terry like
they sat down with some posters
on an oak tag yep plotted out this how
do we look the best how can we and you
know what they looked very gracious they
looked too gracious i didn't understand
that that was the plot twist of the
century i didn't understand it because
like i could understand forgiving
someone
eventually for this especially if they
also didn't go
but it's like you were my friend for six
years and you never shared that you
actually had a bad experience with my
husband that is really weird it's the
lying it's not the suing i i do believe
her when she said she was like a young
model she had like no
no one to steer her in the right
direction and her lawyers were like go
after this big plastic surgeon you might
get some money i can totally see that
happening for me the real crime it's the
cover-up it's literally becoming best
friends with heather being in her house
hanging out with her kids and literally
never telling her that six years ago you
suit her husband right and then without
even having to apologize or explain
herself they just forgave her but then
shannon and gina get their asses reamed
well shannon deserved it but gina i felt
bad like because i do think gina i don't
think jean is a bad person at all and i
don't think she's like a [ __ ] starter i
think in that moment gina really felt
compelled to share with her based on her
own personal experience and also like i
do feel like i would feel the same way i
mean the fact that we didn't get to the
entrees and all that nobody's going to
waste and like the whole party was
ruined was i thought ahead there's like
honestly entire demeanor after that like
i would have i just she could have done
better in my opinion she should have
ended the whole party like yeah they're
all standing around like the food's
right there and like we're not eating
what like what about a to-go bag
like i'm hungry a doggy bag yeah yeah or
like kick out the nefarious actors and
keep the people eat the food the
conversation between emily and nicole
was so funny emily's such a queen and by
the way emily slid into my dms last
night and i told her to come on the toes
like whenever she's in new york it was
just like an amazing experience she was
being so funny because she's really not
like a great shade thrower she's just
like a smart woman who speaks the truth
and so when she's like sit down and
she's like i'm literally sitting there
like
she couldn't stop saying sit you know
nicole really thought she was doing
something and like emily's just like
takes no [ __ ] but she's not like a she
doesn't have rehearsed lines in her head
she just says what comes to her mind
right but i would say that nicole has
even less
lines that are working for her one no
but i think she's literally rehearsed
those lines like she had them in her
back pocket and then she runs out of
things to say calls her dumb when she's
a lawyer and i told her
and tells her to go on a diet and that
for me is always it is the unforgivable
offense and mary cosby it just happened
nicole goodbye i'm done with you i don't
ever want like for me that is so low and
so not creative call her an irrelevant
ugly call her something more creative
like i just i think that is vile and
disgusting and i like you're in my book
forever i despise you no i just think in
any situation going after someone's
looks is just
tacky it's it's like
you lose yeah but i guess you don't know
emily enough well enough to go after
something about her personality or her
life right and you know what i actually
did really like dr jen like immediately
got up and was like i'm not sitting with
this person who just said something like
that like i actually uh grew an
appreciation for dr jen yeah even though
like i'm still even though i did fast
forward to her scene with her husband
you know what i i thought about it but
it was already too far in to fast
forward and i was like you know what let
me just see like before i jury let me
give them a chance but you guys you can
pass forward you know like she works and
he he doesn't miss her i don't care
yeah he eats blueberries and we also got
a personal scene right after that oh
with emily and shane and i didn't fast
forward that because i find them to be
incredibly interesting it was so
beautiful this scene
i i mean it's always hard i'm sure to
like go have a date night with your
husband who's already like not good on
camera yeah and to have a conversation
and usually it's like i don't give [ __ ]
what's going on in your life and like
you're working and you don't see each
other whatever but i thought the
conversation that they had about faith
and like shame me too shane being like
close to dying and like because he had
his faith like he wasn't scared and
emily like being so glad that like their
daughter has is like you know embracing
i guess she's getting baptized and and i
guess they'll become mormons because
that's what shane is and emily doesn't
have a religious background
i was just like this is
like this is a real conversation
three-dimensional conversation yeah and
you know what i actually thought it was
very cool that emily let her kids like
kind of grow up and choose most kids
don't get that like grow up and she's
choosing because like her step sisters
are in it like i actually thought that
was extremely cool no and when emily was
like you know sometimes i get so angry
and we've seen her get that angry you
know when like kelly dodd called her
husband like a loser or whatever she
gets so ingrained she has no outlet to
kind of bring her back down to earth and
she was like maybe because i don't have
a religious background or faith in in
something larger and i think that's you
know sort of stymied me in my life it
was just so introspective i was like no
it was a real like conversation about
like serious things about growth like it
was actually a conversation i don't
think we've ever seen on a show no it
was but it was so real and lovely and i
thoroughly enjoyed it with the sunset
and emily was looking like the snatchers
and the filet looked so good and shane
is just so funny and shane doesn't drink
so it's just so interesting like he
always drinks a diet coke it was just
really beautiful and they deserve to
have you know some
some highlight reels after what they've
been through i agree and i also felt
really good about my decision to
consciously stand emily simpson from
like day one because i just feel like
it's really paying off now i think she's
in like the prime of her life like her
marriage troubles are being worked on
she had a lot of health problems with
her hip and she's looking great like i
just feel really good about my decision
to stick with her yeah and i feel really
good about my decision to not give up on
gina i agree and you know what i've
been so
pleasantly surprised by gina she's
really getting up there for me and even
though this is by far not the worst
crime shannon has committed in her
tenure as a housewife
i do have to say like and i've i've
really supported her throughout the
years because at her worst because of
what she went through and i and i think
that like
of course a lot of women you know expert
a lot of women on the show go through
divorce they go through cheating you
know they go from the big house to the
smaller house but i i feel like when
shannon was going through it at the
start like she wasn't equipped and we
all had to like rally around her and
like give her the strength that she
didn't have because some of the other
women like they're fine yeah they can
handle it they can handle it and i felt
like shannon needed the support and she
was acting out in all these crazy ways
doing things that i wouldn't defend but
like i just not gonna give up on our
girly
but now she's in a great place and she
has a great man she's got the house and
her girls are like so grown and they're
her friend and her plate is is a light
it's light and
to still be acting in this way and and
you know after how many years on the
show not realizing that if there's
something like someone's
lawsuit in their business practice and
it's
it's serious to not go straight to
heather
at best
on camera you know or she could have
done it off camera and given her a heads
up i do think that there's some
shadiness involved and and i'm kind of
leaving shannon in the dust no it's just
like everything like shannon's way of
being a housewife it's just so tired
like it's just not gonna cut it anymore
yeah no she's like making a mess and
she's getting caught and everyone else's
is
it's like they're all like now for
accountability whereas like before with
with vicky and tamara like it was all so
messy so shannon was like perfect for
that but this group it's just like not
everyone's just being like honest and
straightforward and mature with everyone
and like shannon's just not cutting it
yeah i feel like
she might get left in the dust a little
bit if she doesn't
change her ways yeah
so it was a very good episode like
really really good i was very surprised
yeah me too and by the end like heather
had me turned me too she turned me
around and i liked that she gave gina
and emily like the time of day they went
to lunch and i think that she realized
that her anger was definitely misplaced
by them and she was just like wanting
she couldn't yell at nicole because she
wanted to come out looking good but she
needed someone to yell out yeah and so
shannon and gina it was but i just this
the three of them at lunch i was like
this is a team i can definitely get
behind yeah i agree and it's clear that
they
like develop a strong friendship so i'm
excited to see that it was really good
yeah it was great um
so that was the tv recap anything else
you want to talk about before we wrap up
today's episode no that's all she wrote
for me thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast
millennial morning show where we deliver
the five stories that you need to know
every monday through friday on youtube
so if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
we found so it's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i have radio catwalks all
the places wherever you listen to
podcasts find us the more you chose to
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are and
if you meet to this end to the end of
this episode congratulations to let us
know that you are true toaster who
listens all the way to the end why don't
you drop a fish emoji on our most recent
instagram to commemorate all the fish
that was not eaten from the nobu dinner
had their through agreed have a great
day everyone we'll see you tomorrow bye